let's talk about the serious going ons
of
uh of oregon portland federal judge
denies oregon attorney general's motion
to restrict
federal police actions now this story is
very very simple it's basically
let me just read you the quick context
federal judge friday denied a temporary
restraining order
that oregon's attorney general sought to
restrict federal officers tactics in
portland
finding the state lacked legal standing
and presented scant evidence to support
allegations that federal officers were
illegally snatching people off city
streets
boom that's what we've been waiting for
the fake news they've all of these
outlets have been running rampant being
like they're snatching people off the
streets
when they actually went to court and the
judge was like can you
show us them doing this they were like
no your honor but
get out and the judge was like okay get
out of my courtroom
denied it's not real they're not doing
this
nope so how is it that all of these new
news outlets are saying
unmarked uniformed uniformed
is even mean naked we get to this point
now where
we've talked about it ladies and
gentlemen on this program you you have
heard us talk about the game of
telephone that journalists play
yup i would like to present to you the
most extreme game of telephone we will
we have seen yet
but first let me read this next
paragraph a little bit understanding
us district judge michael w mossman
issued his ruling two days
after hearing about 90 minutes of
argument by the phone by phone
conference
it comes on the 58th consecutive day of
protests
are we really at day 58 it's like it's
like
every time i read a new article they're
claiming it's a day later i lost track
yeah
time's weird right now okay i guess
we're on day 58.
uh so yes quote because it has not
shown it is vindicating an interest that
is specific to the state itself i find
the state of oregon lacks standing here
and therefore deny its request for a
temporary restraining order
oregon attorney general ellen rosenblum
had urged the judge to bar
federal officers from engaging in
unconstitutional police state type
tactics
alleging the federal officers have
violated protesters rights to free
expression
and assembly unreasonable search and
seizure and due process
the attorney general and her lawyers
referenced two incidents two
i told i said this it was two videos
that's it
in which men in camouflage fatigues took
michael pettibone of downtown at 2am
placed him in an unmarked van and took
him to the courthouse for questioning
another person the next day
was caught on a widely circulated video
on social media being led away to an
unmarked dark van by men in camouflage
later identified as customs and border
patrol officers
the suit was filed against the u.s
marshals service and the fps
the judge determined for the purposes of
the court hearing that petty bone stop
was likely done without probable cause
now that's interesting
but had little information about the
unidentified man in the video
that's interesting for sure on twitter
mark morgan a senior official with
customs and border protection referred
to a person in a video
who border patrol agents approached on
the streets of portland and moved the
suspects to a safer location
now that's insane inside the courthouse
for for questioning to avoid a large
oh no no no i'm sorry i'm sorry i should
have read the full thing first a safer
location for questioning
to avoid a large and violent mob
suspecting he had previously assaulted a
federal officer
or destroyed federal property he
provided no further information about
the encounter
they say the state has presented just
one example of an arrest without
probable cause and one example of an
unreasonable seizure
that is the sum total of the evidence
before me that underpins the legal
injuries the state asserts in its brief
the judge wrote in both circumstances of
uh
of a federal seizure it is either
admitted or clearly visible that the
agent's uniforms
say police yes wow so they
counter contradict themselves who did
that
well i guess this is two different
articles but uh this is
they clearly say that the uniforms said
police the judge is straight up saying
like
in what was it in the video in both
instances of the evidence presented
before me
their uniforms clearly say police so
what is this unmarked unidentified
unmarked vehicle okay but to be fair the
judge did say no probable cause
yeah that's that to me is surprising and
i'm gonna defer i'm gonna defer to the
experts because i
i would believe that the the federal uh
you know
defense or whatever would would prove
or try and present an argument for
probable cause and i think they did they
said they thought this guy
was somebody who was damaging property
and they wanted to move him to a safer
location so there wouldn't be a violent
mob
that's i that's actually fair you know
yeah but but i'll tell you what look
the federal government has its own
interests in mind and if they're saying
no probable cause
well there you go however the judge
still told them nah they can keep doing
what they're doing they're clearly
police they're clearly doing their thing
yeah so here's what he says beyond the
two examples the state failed to show
that federal officers were engaged in
any widespread unlawful practice
or that others would be harmed in the
future it has presented no evidence of
any official orders or policies and has
presented no evidence that these
allegedly illegal seizures are a
widespread practice
despite the broad language in its
complaint oregon has shown at most
that this this type of seizure has
happened twice
attorney sheila potter deputy chief
trial counsel for the attorney general's
office had argued
that secretive maneuvers by federal
officers make other protesters fear
they'll be snatched off the street blah
blah blah okay
we get the point all we needed to hear
from the judge
was that the only evidence they could
present clearly
identified these these men as police yep
you can argue that the seizures were
unconstitutional i will absolutely
accept the judge's ruling on this one
and i think it's fair i disagree but at
least it's not the judge you know just
like you know jumping up on the table
dancing around and kicking papers at the
at the state you know what i mean true
they're saying okay okay we get it
probably you know it seems like there's
no probable cause but they're clearly
cops
it's not widespread it was a couple
instances
right fair point what especially when
the next like i think it was a week
afterwards uh there was a press
conference and they were showing
the actual uniforms saying you can
clearly see police you can clearly see
you know the badge numbers look yeah
there it is check it out right here so
you can see it on there on the
you know their arm the the badge number
and there's customs and border
protection right here
boom nz39 and then and then they talk
about how these
these federal officers were getting
doxxed by antifa so it's like of course
like they don't even talk about that in
the article that we just read
right well so that was just like the
judge's ruling but look
this article's been going around because
it's hilarious this is beyond parody
unidentified federal agents and it's
literally got his patch
that's amazing he's he's actually
identified in the picture they're using
check this out check this out shameful
here's what vox wrote this is
this it look man i feel like i'm reading
some kind of action
book or or graphic novel just not
something based in reality
okay in fact outside the context of a
domestic insurgency like the troubles in
northern ireland
there is no example of state security
forces being deployed
under circumstances like this inside any
democratic state you about to drop some
bombs on them tim
no i mean any any sane human being who
who understands life
is like what are you talking about we
have state police go out all the time
yeah
well this is the most insane thing i've
ever i've seen written
like how does vox have a green check
mark if you write something like this
to me it sounds like they're admitting
this is insurgency
that's all i hear what did they just say
that that's a good point
outside of the context of domestic
insurgency like northern ireland
there's no example so yeah i guess well
kind of i guess the argument is if this
is an insurgency
then it's justified well that's what
they're saying but look what he says
look at in both let me read this this
paragraph
the the crazy the other crazy thing is
that he's basically comparing this to
the civil war
and i know somebody was waiting for me
to say it i'm he's talking about
reconstruction not me
i didn't i didn't i didn't legitimately
bring it up yeah
the kind of violent federal deployment
over the objections of state and local
officials has no real precedent in
american history
the closest parallels are reconstruction
when union troops
occupied the states of the defeated
former confederacy
and military deployments to the south
during the civil rights era to enforce
enforce desegregation orders so in other
words it's totally legal it's been done
before
can we move on yeah apparently not in
both of those cases
it was uniformed soldiers that were sent
not unidentified state security
from an alphabet soup of obscure dhs
agencies
more fundamentally these troops were
being used to protect moves towards
racial progress
not suppress protesters who were there
to demand it well that's and there it is
blatant lying
right there well no no no it is though
what he doesn't understand is
that's actually a very childlike
view of what they were doing what they
were doing was enforcing the law
when the law said this is what must be
done
period it wasn't about favoring an
ideology or otherwise it was about
the courts had ruled the laws were
passed done
so when it comes to what's going on in
oregon when you try to breach a
courthouse and burn it down and attack
people
the law is very clear on that one so yes
identified state security forces are
being deployed
but see here's how here's what they do
he's playing a very clever game with
this fake news
he says he he says not unidentified
state security
right he didn't actually say in this
paragraph
the guys down there were identified he
used a clever manipulation tactic to
write overt fake news so you assume
right here's what he said in both cases
it was uniformed soldiers not on
unidentified state security forces did
he say
the men down there are unidentified
security forces no
he said during civil war it wasn't them
so you assume it
that way when he comes to the next
paragraph out of
he's it's technically telling the truth
this is the most egregious
egregious example of technically the
truth i have ever seen
and this is what these companies do all
day okay
not every single one but a lot of these
digital only ridiculous
you know companies that just you know
just like
knock out dozens of articles of nonsense
every day
very very clever wording very clever you
know
in both those cases it was soldiers not
evil fascistic
monsters made of you know metal with
claws
to make people assume that's what's
really going on yeah now here's the
funniest thing
there's no example of state security
forces being deployed
in any and uh like this in any
democratic state
first of all you want to talk about like
unmarked masked individuals in full
tactical gear with
with live ammunition going into
residential areas to
purge undesirables there are many
many examples of that happening in
democratic states
you want to argue justification for
whether or not they should or shouldn't
be doing the certain operations they're
all different i want to pretend like
every single operation is the same but
how about we pop over to something
called the bopy
this is brazil's bopy they're basically
like swat and they've been criticized
because
their symbol is like a skull with with
pistols behind it i guess
and a dagger a dagger through its head
down through the top yeah
wow that's pretty brutal so take a look
at this here feller this guy
okay i don't know he's identified he's
got his patch on his arm
in much the same way as like we see in
portland good point
but you can't see his eyes you can't see
his face it's look i'll be fair man it's
similar
and the and these guys were heavily
criticized but they have rifles
like live ammunition the dudes in
portland that are going out are doing
crowd control yeah so you know rand paul
wrote this article saying like
we should de-militarize the police on
that stuff and was making reference to
portland
and i'm like i agree to a certain extent
the issue is more so accountability and
oversight for the use of this
of this machinery technology and
equipment okay so
look if i see a bunch of violent
whatever you want to call it
extremists yeah trying to burn down a
building i'm not going to freak out when
identified federal law enforcement say
get off our property
yeah and then defend themselves yeah
it's like they really think everyone has
no idea what happens
after the peaceful protesters well they
don't even leave they're still there
it's just
when the the rioters pick up and start
attacking did you know about the uh the
few guys that that stood there
there was a couple uh hero black men
that stood and and blocked them
where last night in portland they they
stood and i don't know the guy's name
awesome dude um i think it's like
freedom of speech something
uh i i don't know his tag but they stood
there they locked arms and actually
stopped
and he was like yelling he's like look
if you guys really think that you know
black lives matter
you will join me i'm not afraid to stand
here and he stood there and blocked
blocked the the guys from breaking on
the barricade last night i don't
know powerful video i don't think they
do think that though i think these far
left insurgents but they they they held
back the antifa
for sure from breaking down the right
it's pretty cool to see that though when
he asked that crowd if they really cared
yeah these people are just using this as
a cover
they show up dude we've talked about it
when they showed up
the occupy people the far left as the
socialist ship at the trayvon martin
march in uh in new york and then steered
the crowd in the wrong direction
away from the organizers the organizers
were like we're gonna go to one police
plaza and protest the nypd
and then the occupy people ran to the
front and steered the crowd towards wall
street
and all of those protesters like that
became socialist protesters yep exactly
and that's what i was saying listen
is what i was saying about the bank
robbery thing yesterday if you
if you're marching with someone who's
leading you to wall street chanting you
know like we are the 99 percent
you're not protesting police brutality
anymore you might think you are but no
one's gonna say you're like you're
marching behind the dude against
you know wall street or whatever thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 p.m if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you